hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video von mir
ich habe euch mal wieder auch schon
gesagt hey ich habs einfach mal begrüßen
sind mal wieder die möglichkeiten ja
auch twitter videos so zusammen wie ihr
irgendeinen schwachsinn macht und ich
reagierte jetzt drauf was wir haben es
hier ganz klar mit einem jungen
feuerwehrmann zu tun bei dem gerade ein
notruf reinkommt ich hoffe dass alles
gut ausgegangen
du konntest das feuer löschen wurde auf
jeden fall nicht das vorher schon kann
es im lukas shop weil da ist immerhin
feiert der minister von de luca ich
würde ich mir fragen vielleicht in call
of duty world zwei spielen kannst oder
so und nicht zuletzt ein luca minister
punkte erstmal danke für die werbung für
meinen job ich könnte schon merkwürdig
auf meinem kanal spiel das habe ich auch
schon einige male gemacht und ein paar
psycho die videos von mir wie auch über
eine million aufrufe wo ich da gesagt
habe also ein bäcker aber gerade man
kann nicht so gut ausweichen das sind
hängt allerdings musste wissen dass ich
so circa der beschissenen spieler bin
den cad je gesehen hat also ich glaube
das wird nix beim nächsten video hat mir
eine zuschauerin gesagt hatte matt für
mich gemacht also sonst endet und hatte
irgendwie bilder von mir reden und dann
irgendwie kundenunternehmen dazu film ab
mit diesem feld darf was hat
hat sie das video zum ersten mal gesehen
habe habe ich mir echt so gedacht so wo
die guten alten zeiten bei uns war es da
aber ist doch so in der schule dass die
meisten halt irgendwie so nokia handy
hatten oder so 1 audio da kamen so
langsam dieser iphones raus und die
samsung handys die touch display hatten
und dann hat man im unterricht auf die
handys gerückt meint hubert barth nur
dass das hier irgendwie bei einer
leinwand der fall war und ja dann einen
schuh dagegen geworfen wurde
warum bekomme ich so unfassbar häufig
videos zugesendet wie leute ihnen das in
den müll schmeißen
vielleicht weil man content müll ist
schnee bis in die niederungen wirklich
welche klartext wenn das wirklich so im
fernsehen lief das ist sicher die beste
wettervorhersage die ich hier gesehen
habe ich mein endlich ist das ganze mal
alter da sagt die glatteisgefahr und
dann fällt sie direkt was ist mit meinen
haaren endlos und coole klasse e klasse
da muss ich ehrlich gesagt gar nichts
mehr zu sagen dass das ist nicht von
justin bieber ich mag einfach die
papiere
warum läuft sieht als eine hecke warum
läufst du da jetzt zu einem baum am
abend in haifa das ist mit dir immer
rein und gucken meine videos apropos
videos freund ich würde mich nur bei
euch bedanken und zwar so wie derzeit
deutschland schnellst wachsender kahl
war warum warum der abonniert michael
bitte eine sehr gute frage und ja ich
gehe auf die video daisy sind nächstes
jahr in köln und in berlin und ja ich
werde dann einfach auf die arena
draufgehen und dann bin ich auf den
video game 800 schüler steht in sachen
lukas ehrenhafter logisch text ein
wasserflugzeug ist aber auch eine sehr
gute entscheidung die sache ist ich
bekomme sehr auf die frage nicht
gestellt wo ist eigentlich vita ja der
ist damals bei meinem umzug von einem
jahr wurde er von den warum mit den
fahnen die also die denn die die
möbelpacker die erwarten durst das ist
kein spruch deswegen freunde traurige
musik hier schwarz weiß ihr seht schon
an der stelle eine ganz kurze schweige
zehn sekunden für vitali
[Musik]
okay war ich dann auch nur per du
stinkst gehen mit den duschen
das ist einfach ein fünfjähriges mädchen
das mich gerade gelöst hat ich meine ich
kann jetzt nicht zurück sagen ich meine
sie süß sie ist 5 bis 5 ich bin vier mal
so alt wie sie ja ich liebe solche
videos die leute so richtig schnell
liegen dieser rubik's cube lösen oder so
eine pyramide mit so komischen farben
und was alles also wir schauen uns das
jetzt mal an er werde ich bestimmt
gleich lösen
der hat gleich was nächstes video warum
wird mein job immer mit mülltonne
verbunden ich mein okay ich bin nehme
ich wieder müll habe und ich stinke
ihnen mülltonne und beim content dessen
müll also irgendwie macht das dann auch
wiederum sind also ok danke für die
färbung und so ein cooles in einem topf
gekauft das war warum schmeißt es auf
den boden
hallo freunde über einen web slices
lassen sich einrahmen das muss das ist
ärgerlich ich mag bieber meine blitzer
wird nichts zu bereiten so wie jeder
andere sondern eine ganz besondere art
und wie das zeige ich euch jetzt also
sie hat sich mit einem greenscreen
reingeht in meinem zimmer hier sehen wir
mein kinderzimmer und wird uns jetzt
zeigen wie man die lücke zwar richtig
herstellt als allererstes braucht ihr
erstmal eine luca pizza das ist
definitiv eine luca pizza
ihr müsst ihr dann ganz einfach
auspacken so wie jeder am pizza ist
diese pizza auch in folie eingelegt
natürlich befinden sich auf einer pizza
auf seinen stadien auf dieser pizza ist
aber leider noch seine armee drauf damit
dass eine richtige luca pizza ist müsst
ihr die salami natürlich auch entfernen
so nun dass eure pizza komplett
ausgepackt und jetzt müsst ihr sie nur
noch in den backofen werfen bin ich weiß
wie wir für die pizza ausgepackt in den
backofen und dann fliegt sie quasi mit
pappe in den backofen rein den ofen
müsst ihr nur auf 1500 grad vorheizen
und dann zehn sekunden 1500 grad
vorhalten und zehn sekunden warten genau
das ist so schmeckt die pizza wirklich
am besten wenn die plätze fertig ist
sollte sie denn circa so aussehen bei
der pizza wurde zwar schon mal
abgerissen aber beschweren kann ich mich
da normalerweise bist du wirklich darauf
achten freunde also wenn hier eine pizza
von mir doch irgendwo zu hause rumliegen
habt ihr einfach mal aus schmeißt die
mit verpackung in den backofen 1500 grad
vorheizen zehn sekunden backen und dann
bekommt er eine an
ist eine ritze das ist das ist dann
einfach dass es die beste geschmacks
erfahrung die wir haben werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir waren das komische menschen die müll
sachen an hatten und sich eine schnabel
in form von plastik ins gesicht gestellt
haben
[Applaus]
mich wundert hier in dem format nichts
mehr
ich glaube das ist so tief der cape ob
sinkt also irgendwelche asiatischen
musiker oder so das ist jetzt eine ganz
eigene musikrichtung dort sein eigenes
genre und in dem tweet stand ich
nochmals reagieren wollt ihr das
schreibt mal in die kommentare und las
man leichter und bei wie vielleicht
machen wir machen 10
wenn wir zehn like schaffen freude dann
reagiere ich auf kate warum den
workshops immer mit müll verbunden
braucht sie mit ihrem handy an alle
raucher unter euch wenn ihr mann kann es
direkt am start hatte nimmt einfach ein
fahrzeug sowie drei handy an und ich
habe so hart wochen half und zigaretten
immer noch nicht halten was ist mit euch
denn schief gelaufen ich hatte diesen
namen luke schuhe etabliert weil ich
keinen namen für meine community hatte
aber das soll doch jetzt nicht so ne
sekte werden nachher bringen sich noch
leute um für die luxus detail der luft
sei dann schreibt man luc bondy
kommentare community die ganze
fly aus versteht ihr wegen flugzeuge
warum warum warum schickt man mir sowas
ich sein denken sich die leute die mir
sowas schicken dann irgendwie jahren
könnte jetzt bestimmt auch im stift und
haut ihn auch irgendwie geht ist das
mega geil gemacht und ich liebe es auch
wenn leute sich die arbeit machen und
irgendwie sachen mal einem meter
schenken oder briefe schreiben oder so
ich feiere das wir wollen wir sowas
durchzulesen und ich habe ja im letzten
video gesagt dass ich mich gerade darum
knapp einen cent was machen und ja ich
habe jetzt fast an moskau ich werde
jetzt in den nächsten tagen irgendwann
an die canal beschreibung auf meinen
kanal jahr die kanal beschreibung auf
einem kanal wer hätt's gedacht eher
wenig adresse reinpacken sobald wir
diese ganzen rechtlichen sachen dahinter
geklärt haben
und dann könnt ihr mir demnächst per
post zusenden also spielzeug oder
irgendwas was sich in videos zeigen soll
oder pakete oder gebastelte zu
verbriefen keine ahnung was also checkt
die nächsten tage mal ab und zu einen
kanal aus und dann werdet ihr dann
adresse finden
[Musik]
warum bekomme ich unter dem titel endet
für luca ein edit vom baby zu gesamt
[Musik]
solo gig weder das hat allerdings auch
von hier hey was geht ab das war es
jetzt hier vom video meine damen und
herren es euch gefallen hat dass
gernemann like da schreibt man den
kommentare lucio irgendwie war die
beleuchtung die ganze zeit richtig
bescheuert oder tut mir leid ist schon
relativ dunkel draußen deswegen muss
sich jetzt jeder das ganz mit der
softbox aufnehmen und ich hasse dieses
natürliche licht und weiter und so fort
ist aber auch egal
ich würde sagen das war es jetzt vom
video und ja jetzt kommt das auto glas
was ihr vom video das war's jetzt ihr
vom video hier können jetzt hier mal den
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auch die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]